[Music]
Christian
all right um before Rachel comes up you
might notice there's a bit of a smell so
we think it's something with their ATAC
um so we are we've kind of called their
church and we're trying to get someone
to come out to kind of take a look so if
we know something happens I don't know
something not good smoke you know what
I'd say that door right there it leads
out there's double doors I mean it's
literally you're like 10t from the exit
to the building so um we do for kids
ministry we also have a whole kind of
protocol with our teachers and such so
if for some reason we end up needing to
just exit there's a plan and um we'll
just you can go out there or through
here okay um all the inam SES in the
room are just freaking
out I'm sure I don't know the other
numbers maybe they're just like ah it'll
work out maybe it's the sevens are all
the sevens kind of like ah it'll be fine
I think everything will be good so
anyway um all right Rachel you want to
come on up and get it
started hello welcome welcome plug your
noses um so excited you're here so happy
to see all of you um first announcement
is please join us uh directly after the
service for a meal at hat Creek um it is
the Hat Creek right next to Woodbridge
Parkway which is just a few miles from
here oh also I'm Rachel my pronouns are
she her sorry forgot to say that um also
hat Creek does have a good playground
for the kiddos if you would like to
bring them it's a great way to meet
people and get to know friends here um
next we have our Five Loaves service day
um we're going to be serving as a group
at the local food pantry this coming
Saturday September 7th from 9:00 a.m. to
12:30 p.m. and that is familyfriendly so
bring all your kiddos you can scan the
QR code that's about to be on the screen
to sign up so we can let them know how
many people to expect um also we are
collecting canned goods and other uh
foods for Five Loaves Pantry food and
saxi so please bring your items next
Sunday um and drop them off in the lobby
so now we are going to exit the kingdom
of noise hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and
simplicity a Sacred
Space a place for
prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold Christ
revelation of God God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you and to mend your heart
may we all come
home thank you
Rachel well you guys I have been
thinking about the um the crazy tosses
and turns of Life uh that arise but one
thing that remains consistent when
you're reading through the Bible
especially the Psalms you hear David
always returning back to like calling
his soul to praise um like kind of
pleading with his own heart and mind
like we will praise the lord we will
come before him with singing we will
enter his courts with praise you know
Awake My Soul oh my soul praise the Lord
you know um it's kind of that return
like in the highs and the lows and if
you've read through the Psalms there's a
lot of lows there's a lot of lows
there's a lot of Highs but it's that
return always to pra so that's what
we're doing right now is returning to
praise in the midst of our crazy so you
guys are invited to stand and sing with
us I will say right away we've had a lot
of like unexpected events we had a
drummer that needed to go out of town
unexpectedly Jesse was fighting some
sickness and we had other people that
had to cancel last minute we're sitting
down in solidarity with Jesse's energy
level tonight and you guys are welcome
to stay seated if you would like if
you're feeling like I could just use
some rest while we worship God um he is
willing to receive our praise from any
posture he is not against us sitting but
I also invite you if you would like to
stand to your feet and put yourself in
whatever posture feels comfortable to
enter into his Gates tonight with
Thanksgiving with joy um calling
ourselves back to that beginning of
Praise all right we're going to learn a
new song tonight um and so you guys
follow along and sing out as it starts
to feel more more familiar and uh we're
going to get
[Music]
started
Mercy Rising with the rising of the
sun
goodness rushing in and feeling of my
lungs your faithfulness your
faithfulness
is here and now the
evidence is all
[Music]
around I bless your name I give you
praise today is a day for
singing Awake My Soul come on praise the
Lord today is a day for singing
[Music]
oh my
soul the
Lord
oh my
soul today is a day for
[Music]
singing her new
song is Welling up from deep inside of
me there is New
Life Hallelujah I have been redeemed
I've been
redeemed eyes the Lord I give you
praise today is the day for singing
Awake My Soul awake make my soul come on
and praise the Lord today is the day for
singing let's sing that
again I bless your name I give you
praise today is the day for
singing yeah Awake My Soul come on and
praise the Lord today is the day for
singing
sing Oh My
Soul
oh my
soul
praise the Lord oh my soul
oh my soul today today is a day for
singing
today today is the day for singing
[Music]
today is the day we bless your
name from the valley to the mountain the
desert to the
Fountain oh I will praise
you from the morning to the evening as
long as I am breathing today is the day
we singing let's sing that again
from the valley to the mountain the
desert to the Fountain do I will praise
you yeah from the morning to the evening
as long as I am breathing today is a day
for singing today today today it's a day
for singing oh
today today
is a day for
singing I bless your name I bless your
name I give you praise to to praise
you oh wake my soul come on and praise
the Lord oh today is a day for singing
sing Oh My
Soul
oh my
praise the Lord oh my soul
soul today is the day for singing let's
sing that again oh my soul from the
valley to the mountain the desert to the
Fountain oh I will praise you
from the morning to the evening as long
as I breathing today is the day for
singing today is the day for
singing today is a day for
singing all right you kiddos are
dismissed to go to the club classrooms
and your teachers are going to meet you
over here at these doors and you can
just follow them
back yall have
fun and thank you Maggie and
[Music]
Kelly anybody else who might be serving
tonight we appreciate you guys so
[Music]
much and we're going to go ahead now and
transition to the prayers of the
people if this is your first time with
us this is a tradition that's passed
down over Christian history and it's an
opportunity for us to lift up the things
that we're kind of carrying on our
hearts burdens struggles um a friend or
family member that you've been praying
for or are thinking about it's just an
opportunity for us to say those names
out loud or speak that situation out and
hold them together before God um
believing that we share each other 's
burdens and that he also meets Us in
those moments so uh we're going to read
aloud from the screens and you'll see
everyone reads together the portions
that are in red and then we'll take a
break for us to kind of speak out those
names and then we'll close out the
prayer together
again Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
[Music]
you Johnny
Owen C
[Music]
sickness
teachers for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud and for those
that we have kept in our hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and Light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence amen
[Music]
here is where I lay it down every birden
every Crown this is my
surrender this is my
surrender here is where I lay it down
every Li and every doubt this is my
surrender and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to here is where I lay it down every
burden every Crown this is my
surrender this is my
surrender here is where I lay it down
every
lie and every doubt this is my
[Music]
surrender and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to and I will make room for you
to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
[Music]
to shake up the ground of all my
tradition Break Down the Walls of all My
Religion your way is
better your way is
[Music]
better shake up the ground of all my
tradition Break Down The Walls of all My
Religion your way is
better your way is
better shake up the CR of all my
tradition Break Down the Walls All My
Religion your way is
better your way is
better shake down the walls of all my
tradition Break Down The Walls of all My
Religion your way is
better your way is
better and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to and I will make room for
[Music]
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to here is where I lay it down you you
are all I'm chasing now this is my
surrender this is my
surrender here is where I lay it down
you are all I'm chasing now this is my
surrender this is my surrender
[Music]
if you were here with us last week you
heard Brett talk about um getting
uncomfortable and going against the flow
and how a fish doesn't just usually swim
upstream you know doesn't usually go
against the grain um and how we're
called as Believers to make decisions
that sometimes put us against what's
common against what we would naturally
choose in our own flesh um and that song
that we just sang is one of those for me
that I come back to in those moments of
asking God shake up the things in me
that have gotten um stale shake up the
things that have started to harden and
callous and crystallize where really I
need the flow and the fluid of the Holy
Spirit to come and soften my heart heart
to come and break me out of my
molds and um it is
uncomfortable but the
payoff is getting this deeper
understanding of God's love not just for
me but for the world around me for the
people around me for our
community and um as Jesse leads us in
this next song I just want you to
reflect um maybe on your own
relationship with Christ and maybe the
way that he wants to meet you and expand
that view of his love because there's
goodness there he always meets us in our
discomfort with his
grace with his steadfast
love so Jesse go ahead and start us off
and let's let's meet him here
[Music]
I'm caught up in your
presence now I just want to sit here at
your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy
moment and never want
oh I'm not here for
[Music]
blessings Jesus you don't know me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want on
[Music]
you and I'm
sorry when I've just gone through the
motions I'm
Sor when I just sing another song take
me back to where we
started I open up my heart
to
[Music]
you and I'm
sorry when I've come with my
agenda I'm
sorry when I forgot that you're enough
take me back to where we
started I open up my heart
to
[Music]
you I'm C up in your
presence and I just want to sit here at
your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy m
never want to
leave oh I'm not here for
[Music]
blessings Jesus you don't owe me
anything
anything more than
anything that you can do
I just want
you I just want
you and nothing
else nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you and nothing
else and nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you and nothing
else and nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you nothing
else nothing nothing else
Jesus nothing else will
do wo
[Music]
oh I'm caught up in your
pra I just want to sit here at your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy
moment I never want to leave
oh I'm not here for
[Music]
bless Jesus you don't know
me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want you
[Music]
yes God we want
you we want more of your goodness more
of your
Justice more of your
[Music]
grace we want you to transform the way
that we do family the way that we do
friendships and marriages and
Partnerships the way that we do work
[Music]
God would you make us a people after
your
heart would you touch the pieces inside
of us that have gotten hard and would
you soften
them would you give us a steadfast heart
that runs after you and the things of
God and changes the world around around
us for the
better thank you for your light thank
you for your
[Music]
kindness thank you for meeting with us
here tonight it's in Jesus name I pray
amen would you guys turn to the people
around you and make them feel welcomed
and at home
[Music]
well Grace and
peace good to be with you all my name is
Brett and uh yeah it's a joy a joy to
welcome you into this space
and uh that includes those joining us
online love yall lots and anyone here
tonight who is new thank you for for
being Among Us I know it can take a lot
of courage to come through those double
doors and enter into a new community new
space so we just want you to know that
we're really really glad that you're
here so uh we're in part five of our
series titled The Parables of Jesus and
next week we'll be wrapping up the
series uh and so Parables of course
these there were these short stor
stories that Jesus used as basically
devices for for teaching and some of
them are are kind of shorter some are
longer this this one tonight is uh it's
very short so the title of the message
is um the parable of the
leaven and also known as the parable of
the yeast so our passage is just one one
short verse Matthew Chapter 13 Verse
33 he that is Christ told them still
another Parable the Kingdom of Heaven is
like yeast that a woman took and mixed
into about 60 pounds of
flour she's making a lot of bread there
until it worked all through the
dough and that's the whole Parable I
mean I told you some of these are short
so uh about nine years ago I went
through
a a phase of um bread
making I really got in this idea I just
I loved the idea of like homemade bread
like just the smell you I mean wating
through the house and I I had this kind
of inclination though to like I wanted
to do it like the oldfashioned way with
the slow rise you know method and uh in
fact I think my first attempt like I
even tried it without like where you try
to just capture yeast from the
air I mean talk about a long then I was
like okay this is very very hard um so
then I put some yeast in it but it was
still this like method that it just took
forever like basically you work it
through you know and then you like put
in the pan and like cover it and then
what do you do you just let it
sit and sit and sit I mean it was like
12 hours I mean it was forever and uh I
tried this like a few times
and I eventually I just couldn't take it
like it was just so long like my life I
guess my life just wasn't conducive to a
15 hour baking cycle you know it's like
I just oh my gosh I can't do this I
finally eventually just broke down and
got a bread maker and I was just like
okay just let it you know just do it was
it was still kind of homemade esque but
I mean obviously it wasn't uh it wasn't
quite the same and uh then I had a phase
where I I got into home brewing
beer uh this was very shortlived uh so
the first I mean I it's like complicated
like you get all the stuff you know and
I was there in my kitchen and I'm like
you boil it's called the wart I think W
RT uh sounds gross you as you boil this
wart just this brewed beer concoction in
this and you like pour it in this five
gallon jug and it has this little topper
and it burps is what it calls it lets
like as the yeast is like eating the
sugar and it's I mean it's gr and then
you just put it in your closet
like a
month and it just sits there
just it's like some weird science
experiment so you go there you do that
then you bottle it and then you let it
sit again for like you add a little more
sugar and then let it kind of the ye
keep doing this thing like another week
or two I mean it's been a while so it
was it took you know it was a few weeks
uh then finally I remember like the day
it was like I mean been like a two-month
process and that's like the day of like
my first you know home brew when I crack
could open and it was the worst beer
I've ever tasted in my life I mean it
was just oh god oh Lord oh this is
undrinkable I mean it was so bad and and
I immediately literally one batch of
that's all I did with home brewing like
one batch and I was like out I can't do
this like I just don't have the patience
uh I'm just going to buy a Shiner boach
and uh then I went through a um roasting
my own coffee
phase yep you're like do you never learn
no I don't I don't learn I just keep
making the same mistakes over and over
so we so I got this like old school like
a popcorn popper like the thing where
it's like the hand crank sh and I poured
the green like coffee beans into that
and then I would just sit there and put
it on like medium a sheet on the stove
and said you had to keep it moving
perpetually you know so it just sit
there for like 20 25 minutes
like sh I mean just ad nauseum and it
was so challenging like what I found was
if the outside was done perfectly the
inside was still green I would be like
ah perfect roast I would go to grind it
I had this hand grinder because I'm a
glutton for punishment and I was just
like like I couldn't you know so then I
would have to like scald the outside to
get the inside cooked long story short
it was just a disaster like and then I
had a gardening phase uh which I won't
go into for the sake of time uh you see
the point is regardless of kind of
whatever phas and season I was in beer
coffee bread making gardening whatever
like I I just basically I kept running
into the same problem which is that in
essence I love the idea of taking things
slowly maybe you do too like you know
just like yeah wouldn't that be great
like don't we all just need more kind of
home brewed home baked Home roasted home
grown like yeah you know I love the idea
of that the problem was it was exactly
as
advertised slow as Christmas and so I I
love the idea of it but over and over I
kept falling into the same like trap
right because in essence like the
slowness though that's why it tasted
good or at least in theory um could
taste better you know what I mean like
once you get kind of perfect that's
that's but that's the whole point in the
process is like yeah it's not instant I
mean this is where I kind of like what
what I want is instant homebaked bread
fast home brewed beer quick backyard
gardens and lightning fast Home roasted
coffee you know like this is this is
what I want but like but that's PR
precisely sort of upending the process
and I think in a lot of ways this is
where sort of like the ways of Brett and
the ways of God sort of part because
what we learn in this
Parable is is that the work of God in
the world is like home brewed beer or
slow Rising bread it's marked by an
unhurried
patience it it seems that God has has
all the time in the world like I'm so
I'm in a hurry and God has all the time
in the world I I think the uh we're kind
of getting out here is the virtue of
patience and I think this virtue like
humility um is probably incredibly
underrated in kind of modern culture um
and even in the church I mean I'm I'm
thinking uh you know for a lot of us
probably whether or not we are patient
that's like I don't know about you
that's like the 20th thing on my list of
you know areas I need to grow you know I
mean like when was the last time you saw
it Facebook or Instagram or Tik Tok
where someone's like about patience I'm
really working on patience and five
reasons patience is awesome you know
it's like this isn't a super popular you
know
idea
and I I I think in in kind of a a
similar way um well it's often these
kind of underrated things that actually
turn out to be the most important things
I think this is why we actually do need
a tradition like something broader
bigger than us where it's not quite so
captured by the spirit of the
age
and in this way I think we can be kind
of invited into a different Rhythm into
a different way of being in the world a
much more patient
way there's a quote from pastor Pastor
uh he actually passed away a few years
ago I loved his blog uh Kim
febus and uh he put it this way he said
you know why people are
impatient because we need to be in
control to feel that we are in
charge when I came across that I just
stopped because I had never linked
patience to control for whatever reason
like this is just lost on me I don't
know it's just like I don't know I just
don't like to wait I just don't like it
why you know why aren't you more patient
like I don't know just not you know but
I had never really thought thought about
it and I realized like oh like yeah
that's there's something there like why
am I impatient it's often this like you
know what I mean it's it's this inner
kind of a situation a person you know
where it's like ah I can't I I can't
speed it up I I don't get to control it
right it's it's this thing this
situation
where I'm just not in
charge and uh like for example let's say
you're standing in
line at the store we've all had this
experience and it's just moving
painfully slowly and what happens like
we start to get kind of fidgety you know
a little bit
agitated we notice how inefficient and
stupid everyone's being in the line just
oh my gosh like load it fast you know
what I mean like you're not even trying
right and something in US desires to
lash out like to yell can you people
just not hurry up like freaking hurry up
you know but of course social protocols
we zip it you know keep it under
wraps but
inwardly uh we
burn you know what what's going on there
I I
think um it's because in that moment
we're powerless at least we feel
powerless right this is not a person
that we get to have a say about how they
load or Lo unload their groceries or we
just we don't get to say it and so
suddenly we're kind of faced with this
situation this person that we don't get
to control and it's painful it's
difficult we might kind of sum summarize
it by saying how I say wait in
traffic or treat the server when my food
runs late it's an incredibly powerful
indicator of my own spiritual
maturity you see patience a capacity to
accept and work with my life as God has
actually given it to
me like this
this is is there's something so
incredibly powerful about that
invitation but I think it's one we often
miss because God seems to work
differently God works like yeast in
bread slowly quietly
mysteriously in his book the patient
ferment of the early church Theologian
Alan krider summarized the perspective
of the church father trolan on this
topic and he's really Teran is really
thinking about Jesus here in his life
and I want you to pick up on kind of the
notes of patience throughout this quote
he says terlan recounts The Narrative of
Jesus whose
labors unlike Hercules say you know the
Greek God it did not include killing
capturing and stealing but who instead
kept a low
profile Who Bore
reproaches who would not hear of force
seen people who ate at anyone's table
who declined to call for massive Angelic
intervention thinking there of that
moment right on the
cross who rejected the avenging sword
who healed the servant of his
enemy you see the Lord
Jesus showed us the
way
slowly patiently quietly
mysteriously this is how God
works
delightfully
unhurried and so if I I shouldn't say if
when I am in a mod of
forcing pushing impatient with you know
people and problems and situations and
what what's happening there I'm I'm
getting out of of
alignment with the the way that the
spirit of God loves to work in the
world God who is such a good Mama a good
Papa God who is
patient with me and I need that do you
like I need that and so if we need that
can you see where the invitation is for
us to extend that same patience to
others if I need the patience of God
like then of course my neighbors need
the patience of God every person in this
room needs the patience of God and
that's the invitation for us where we're
invited to kind of bring our heart and
mind and life into alignment with this
way of great
love so if we're grateful that God is
patient with us doesn't that say
something about how we're invited to
relate to others the uh the Quaker
writer Parker Palmer uh described a
whole season in his own life where uh he
he needed um just a a kind of patient
Ministry from others as he battled a
season of deep deep
depression so this is taken from his
book He said I had folks coming to me of
course who wanted to be
helpful and sadly many of them
weren't he said they wanted to be
helpful but they just weren't these were
people who would say things like gosh
Parker why are you sitting in here being
depressed it's a beautiful day outside
go go feel the
Sunshine smell the flowers and that of
course leaves a depressed person
even more depressed because while you
know intellectually it's sunny out and
the flowers smell
delightful you can't really feel any of
that in your
body which is dead in a sensory kind of
way and so you're left more depressed by
this good advice to get out and enjoy
the
day there's this one friend though who
came to me Palmer writes after asking
permission to do so every afternoon
about 4:00 sat me down in a chair in the
living room he took off my shoes and my
socks and then massaged my feet he
hardly ever said anything he was a
Quaker Elder and yet out of his
intuitive sense from time to time he
would say a very brief word
like Parker I can feel your struggle
today or or a little further down the
road I feel you're a little stronger at
this moment and I'm glad for that but
beyond that he would say hardly anything
at
all he would give no advice he would
simply report from time to time what he
was intuiting about my
condition somehow he found the one place
in my body namely The Souls of my feet
where I could experience some sort of
connection to another human being and
the act of massaging just in a way that
I really don't have words for kept me
connected to the human
race you see church we hear at the
table we are all on a profound
Journey but the thing is we're going to
have to extend a certain patience
to one another in the midst of it
because folks here are wrestling
wrestling with God wrestling with
questions questions of Theology and
sexuality and scripture and and and what
it all means and how to live we have
folks struggling with substance abuse
folks struggling relationally with
family and marriages folks uh coming out
of divorce going into divor like folks
we're going through things and here's
the Temptation is that when say um I'm
in a good place or at the very least
maybe not struggling with like the thing
they're struggling with then what
happens I just get
impatient we get impatient we feel
shouldn't they be beyond that like why
are they still asking that question
about God it's been a year you know but
no no no no no like this is where we we
have to start to take in the way of
Christ the the
unhurried patience of
God so what does this look like I mean
for us it can look like being in a
Meetup you know you're in that small
group and it's easy to grow impatient
there it can look like um when raising
children oh my goodness Lord have mercy
you know I find I kind of perpetually
expect my children to be about two years
ahead of where they are you know I sort
of want them like it's like the 13 want
them to act 15 if they're 15 want them
acts 17 there're you know I mean and so
on uh and I could save myself so much
grief if I could just chill out you know
and kind of accept them like where they
are just like in like I'm named just
like I hope others can kind of accept me
where I am you know in in all of the the
beauty and the Frailty of of my
moment that's the Grace we're trying to
cultivate um here at the table so in
that moment you feel that frustration
this week it's rising up in you you know
it's just just remember it's a waiting
in line moment it's a fermenting moment
and the patience that you give today you
just might need yourself
tomorrow and as we do that may the
leaven
of the Kingdom work its way through each
and every one of us and through us the
world in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we uh as we come to the table
of the Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
in the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine you might notice that those are
both
fermenting and types of of uh substances
you know let let it be a symbol and a
sign of the patience of God to meet you
right where you're at and to invite you
to show that same grace and patience to
others so the way we'll partake of
communion tonight is we'll form one line
right here down the middle um we'll
start at the front row and then just
kind of work our way back uh we practice
what's called an Open Table meaning if
you're here tonight and something in you
wants to particip ipate then you are
free to do that regardless of your exact
like theology or denomination or
whatever um you're you're welcome to to
participate you should know that the red
is uh wine and the white is grape juice
and then finally you can just partake
whenever you'd like some folks take
right away others like to kind of come
here and kneel at the front and take
that way others return to their seats so
just however you want to partake no one
will lead you through the exact moment
you just do that on your own so this is
the table not of the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so
come you who have much faith and you who
have little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here
long you who have tried to follow and
you who have
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
oh good shepher would you teach me how
to
rest I'm a rushing on will you make me
to lie
down will you build a fold By the Waters
that
refresh will you call my name and Lead
Me safely out
[Music]
from my anxious drive to LA
on from the Restless grind that has put
my mind to
[Music]
see you call me back and gently Slow Me
Down Will you show me now what to l who
and what to
keep oh good
shepherd oh
good Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepherd oh
good slow me
down slow
[Music]
when
mybl with only green and
gold and my grasping hands are afraid
you won't
provide will you pour the wine the Loos
of my
home set your table here with what truly
satisfi oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good shepherd
oh great
great Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down on the busy streets trying to make
myself a
name if the work is yours there is
nothing I can
claim will you lead me home to the
pastures of your
[Music]
peace if the house is yours I'm sting at
your
feet oh good
shepherd oh good
PR Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepher oh oh
good Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down
Slow thank you so much for being with us
this evening you guys are all such a
gift to me um thank you for join joining
us if you're new um we'd love for you to
fill out a card uh at that table on the
way out or you can scan the QR code
right behind you we'd love to just thank
you for coming or answer any questions
you might have um and just say thank you
for being here um if you're in need of
prayer or a hug just somebody to talk to
I'll be here after the service um I'll
stand right over there again my name is
Rachel um I'd love to be there for you
however I can um and don't forget we
have hat Creek Burger uh right after
this and and we love to see you
there uh generosity is a key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship if you
would like to join us in giving
financially you can scan the QR code or
visit the tabl tx.org
okay so now I'm going to send you into
your week with a benediction you can
hold out your hands in a posture to
receive or just open your heart to these
words
you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go filled
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are and go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same Gifts of Grace and unconditional
love to everyone you come into contact
with be blessed we'll see you next
Sunday thank
[Music]
you
good slow me
down slow
down